All right, folks, welcome back.
All right, so this is the Tuesday, January 25th, 2022, ITT mentorship on the YouTube
channel.
All right.
This is the internal range liquidity and market structure shift lecture.
All right, so I gave you homework on the community tab.
If you have not been paying attention to that, that's where I'm kind of keeping you abreast
as to what you should be expecting next or something that just comes to mind that I feel
like sharing.
So this is the link I sent out the other day.
And I wanted you to go through this particular chart and look for reasons that provided the
market structure shift and the buy side and sell side liquidity.
So if you have not done that, please stop the video and do that now.
Otherwise, you're cheating yourself of learning opportunity.
All right, so here is that chart, again, 15 minute time frame on the e-mini NASDAQ 100
futures contract for March delivery 2022.
And take your attention over here.
OK.
This old low and these relative equal highs, see that?
Old low below that is sell stops.
And relative equal highs above that is buy stops.
Now, you could have used this high here.
There's nothing inherently wrong about that.
But whenever I see equal highs like this, and if it's higher than an old high over here,
I'm going to use that.
So that way, there's a little bit of insight for you for your study journal.
The sell side liquidity, you can see that the market trades down, hits that, runs through
it and rallies all the way back up, clearing equal highs.
So the buy stops have been taken here.
OK.
So at both of these price points here and here, that's the, I guess, the point at which
you'll look for or anticipate a market structure shift and you don't force it.
OK.
I'll try to teach my concepts.
It'll talk about market structure breaks or shifts, and we'll use that term interchangeably.
But for intraday, I want you to think about intraday market structure shifts because it's
not necessarily a break in market structure that leads to prolonged multi-day movement.
OK.
What do I mean by that?
If you see a market structure that's bearish and it's broken to the downside, intraday,
that may just lead to an intraday price lag that may eventually see that high be taken
out in the same day.
So that's why I'm using the term market structure shift, not market structure break.
For our conversation here on this mentorship, just know that when I'm going to lean on that
term market structure break, it means a little bit more in context versus an intraday shift
in market structure.
It just means that there's likely a downside draw or an upside draw intraday by saying
the term shift.
OK.
So there's a little bit of semantics there.
All right.
So we have both of these areas here and here where there would be a likelihood of a market
structure shift.
Up here, we look for a fake run above here.
So that fake run above, how do we know it's going to be a market structure shift that's
bearish?
I get that question a lot, even from mentorship students.
What you're looking for is the evidence I'm going to show you here tonight.
OK.
Forget everything else everybody else says about market structure breaks and shifts
and all that stuff.
This is it.
OK.
This is the brass tacks.
There's absolutely nothing else that you need to know about it, I promise you.
If they add anything to it, it's just because they want to sound and look different.
But this is the algorithmic perspective of a market structure shift intraday.
Now keep this price level in mind, so it's essentially $14,600 and $14,820.
We're just eyeballing it, OK?
Now dropping all the way down into a two-minute chart, this is that same particular day.
There's those relative equal highs.
And this run down here, OK?
If you recall, $14,600 and around that $14,860 or so, OK?
If you look at this market structure, without having the levels on your chart, it's easy
to get lost in all of the quote unquote noise, the uninitiated, and I know it's going to
razz the people that don't care to really learn here.
But the uninitiated folks that will watch a video or listen to some of the lectures
I'll put out, they're trying to bring something in, they're trying to bring in their preconceived
notions and ideas about what they think they understand about markets or technical analysis
or something in price action.
I want to kind of like allow you to just put that aside for a moment and just imagine this
chart is the first time you looked at price action for the first time, and that's hard,
but kind of like strip away everything else that you want to bring to the conversation.
No order block discussion, no breaker, none of that stuff, OK?
Supply and demand, Elliott Wave, all that garbage.
If you look at this price action here, when we had this low form, right before this low
was formed, there's a swing high right there.
Now in the first mentorship video I gave you, I mentioned that high frequency trading algorithms
will use market structure on a three minute, two minute, and one minute chart many times
sub one minute.
That would be like 45 second, 30 second, 15 second intervals, OK?
What the algorithms are actually doing, and this is also going to correct a lot of people
out there because they put out misinformation, it's so nonsensical, but I'm challenging you
to go into your charts and see if this is not what's actually going on because it happens
every day.
If high frequency algorithms are operating every single day, then these signatures will
be in the chart, OK?
If you look at this short term high here, right before this low formed, when this high
is taken out right there on that candle, that's significant.
Only, only if this run down here has traded into sell stops, OK, below an old low of some
kind, it could be a double bottom, it could be a single low, OK, but it's got to be trading
under some retail idea that would be viewed as support.
Up here the same thing, we're trading above highs, so we know that above old highs a neophyte's
perspective will be.
These are unknown orders, so therefore that's a